a republican focus group very clearly
turned on Donald Trump this is
fascinating stuff uh many of you know
pollster and focus group leader Frank
Luntz who has been uh working on and and
testing messaging and language and ideas
for the Republican party for a very long
time and recently uh this is about 10
days old at this point in time
um he did a focus group with Republican
voters taking their temperature now
beyond the midterm elections about Trump
and about Trump versus DeSantis this
focus group and of course with any such
focus group there's a question of how
representative is the focus group really
it's anecdotes you're not going to get
with just a couple dozen or a dozen
people you're not going to get a fully
representative sample of some of a group
as large as the Republican voting base
but it's interesting anecdotally
nonetheless take a listen to what some
of these folks say first one word or
phrase that you use to describe Donald
Trump right now uh stay off Twitter
Jamie from Iowa I was just going to say
the same thing um you know his new one
that he's on I think he needs to take a
break from that one Becky
a narcissist Lisa
keep doing what you're doing Andrew
tired
John
unsettling
Melody
High Hopes Marie mistake
John from North Dakota
unrelenting
Kathy
still right Eric devices
Jim
um overdone John from Georgia
fighter
David from California
racist jab from Texas
sanctimonious oh stay super Indiana
who's this man
Nancy from Illinois
uh calculated
I'm gonna do the same thing now with the
governor of Florida Ron DeSantis I'm
going to go in the exact opposite order
right uh promising Stacy from Indiana
oh geez
um
interesting Jeff from Texas badass Kathy
from Pennsylvania a leader
Eric from North Carolina hopeful
Jim from Indiana
Rising date John David from Georgia
I say the same thing fighter David from
California
promising
Andrew from South Carolina
leader John from California
Visionary Melody from Washington amazing
Marie from New York the future
John from North Dakota
no apologies Lisa from New York gutsy
Becky from Virginia you took care of the
party Jamie from Iowa
refreshing later Gregory from Nevada
future of the party
so Frank so that is pretty interesting
now of course it's completely anecdotal
but that sentiment increasingly tired of
trump sick of the Antics sick of the
posts and the like
mirrored by what we are seeing in the
polls increasingly pointing more towards
the idea of Ron DeSantis as the future
of the party now as I've said before I
don't know that this is any big party to
write home about because if DeSantis
were to become the next president of the
United States there is no doubt in the
world
that he would be about as dangerous as
Trump in terms of ideas but far more
dangerous in terms of his ability to
execute because he's less incompetent
um uh that's the the risk and so when we
think about the 2024 Republican primary
not that we vote in it by and large the
question of who do we prefer when the
primary has to be contextualized in who
are we worse off if they actually become
president of the United States and in a
way
an 80 year old incompetent Trump to me
seems less acutely dangerous than
Rhonda santis and I'm willing to have my
mind changed and my feelings may evolve
over the course of the primary remember
the primary in which Rhonda santis has
not even yet said he's participating but
I want to hear from you leave a comment
send an email info at davidpackman.com
send a tweet however you want to get in
touch smoke signals telegrams Etc let me
know what you think about this who would
actually be more dangerous if they
became president I want to hear from you
we will um look at some uh comments on
an upcoming episode of the show quick
break and then we will come back we're
going to talk about 17 guilty verdicts
against the Trump organization that's a
big story and so much more